oh that was loud
just like the others
[Music]
nice this
is what it's like to be lovers
[Music]
you mean it never be
lonely again
spin with me oh endlessly
or at least until the end
please never fall in love again
oh please never fall
in love again please
oh yeah i need to put this in here
oh gosh youtube it takes so long sorry
take something for me to come back guys
i
totally underestimate how long it takes
to have lunch put makeup on
and then update twitch and youtube
my life youtube just doesn't seem i've
got the thumbnail just doesn't seem to
want to
here you go finally
but we have updated the uh
the just giving page it is now
400 pound that is the new goal
welcome back everybody
how are we all feeling
i actually can't see anything in the
chat yet
most restroom is catching up
so i i did this makeup yesterday
and uh i wanted to try and recreate it
but i literally it took me like
like nearly an hour yesterday doing it
and i tried to do it again just now in
like
10 minutes so it's not done very well
but it's okay because you can't really
tell on the camera
it's supposed to look like i've been
scorned by love
it's like like um i've got band marks of
little hearts on my cheeks like
seared score and
final fantasy 2001 trailer nice clay
so welcome to the second part of the
valentine's livestream
it's going so quick today i did not
expect for it to go this quick
so i guess i should just like you know
play some songs before
i'm gonna play among us which is
you know like half an hour away now
you'll play among us in half an hour
um if you have any questions for me
before we start playing
among us then let me know
um also i i've just started to
um do like tick tocks i don't know how
long i'll do it for because i'm still
very confused about what tick tock is
i feel like an old lady now um
but i tried to do a tick tock of like
how i did this makeup
so if any of you want to know then yeah
my legs on tick tock but whatever
it doesn't have much on there you're not
missing out um
i've done such a bad job i just look
like i'm flustered but it's okay it's
not looks like i've been
like i've been um banned
what's on jamie though you've you you uh
you spots it too quiet
most people who don't know technology
tick tock calls that spell it like a
clock
i know i did
there was a whole wardrobe swap that's
production value ah
thank you i mean i was thinking this
morning i was like i really wish i'd
done more for this i wish i could have
like love hearts and stuff and like made
background that was really cutesy but
this is a good thing because
i'm going to be moving house soon and um
in my new house
i'm gonna have a whole boom this is
gonna be amazing because right now i'm
in my bedroom
everything i do is in my bedroom i sleep
in my bedroom i eat in my bedroom
i work in my bedroom i play games in my
bedroom i live stream in my bedroom
so i'm so freaking excited to have
a place where i'm going to have a
separate room to work
to live stream and that means i can have
like this set
up all the time just ready to go and
i can hopefully have like a a more
interesting background than my
clutter of an open wardrobe um
yeah exciting so hopefully the
production value is just going to go up
and up
and because obviously we just got a new
uh computer
um and you guys have already been
telling me how
much better my streams looks i'm so
happy about that
but yeah it's gonna be good
yeah i get you jams sam jones it's
it's tough right uh yeah i don't know
what to say i mean if there's any way
that you could like
move maybe your computer out into the
kitchen or the front room but obviously
i know not everyone can do that
especially when you live in a house
share
with a bunch of people i remember when i
was in london i lived with like
nine people i think it was so there's no
way that you could have your own space
in the kitchen or whatever there
it's tough it's these are very tough
times
um but even i mean i know some people
that have been working from home and do
everything in their bedrooms and their
bedrooms are big enough to get like a
room divider
if it's big enough to do that then do it
because anything to kind of try to
separate the spaces between work and
play
is so good so good
um
but yeah i guess i will get something
out do i want to play guitar or do i
want to play ukulele i don't play
ukulele like
ever anymore i always just get my guitar
just like default to my guitar
[Music]
i did do an open mic in work the other
day and i sang a tainted love
[Music]
what the frick
[Music]
is it raining it's raining
oh someone asked me if it's been snowing
it has been snowing in the uk but not
really much where i
am wow it's very cloudy at the moment
though
[Music]
oh yeah i get you some yeah
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
everybody if you feel like this
everybody don't stop don't miss
all your ladies if you're feeling like
this
[Music]
my
just like that
i love how i started to sing the radio
edit and i just like didn't
[Music]
it's so weird holding my ukulele i'm
like always playing the katana because
i'm trying to get better at it
but i find it like difficult to write
songs i guess because i'm still
[Music]
learning
[Music]
do
this is just the story of a girl who
sold her heart
she needed to forget she needed a fresh
start
be careful what you say cause she no
longer feels the same look at her eyes
see the stains my love
my heart
[Music]
started for a watch to regain the time
she lost
one day it's working like seconds since
both your past crust
sorted for a sweater keeping out this
cold weather
body here to keep so all but it won't
last forever
[Music]
she likes to think she's clever
sorted for our nickels all your worth
when you're so fickle
handed over her i felt it heavy and
brutal
sorted for a key to regain her dignity
stole it all in a box on my earth
[Music]
truly
this is just the story of a girl who
sold her heart
now she's forgotten she's got a fresh
start
be careful what you say cause she no
longer feels the same look at her eyes
see the strains for love
once we
[Applause]
[Music]
make
my love can't you see that you can't
even breathe
it's here's my beach right but your body
won't bleed
my love why did you choose your soul at
you
can offer your ties but you left
one lose my love as you fade i have this
to say sunrise
[Music]
was this not worth the way
this is just the story of a girl who
sold her heart
now she's forgotten she's gonna
start
[Music]
oh
you seen joe's last stream yeah i don't
think you're talking to me it's almost
someone else and yeah
right anyway happy hearts day acoustic
heaven
oh thank you exotic nephilim
sounds great mr just reborn thank you
you can play the campfire song
from spongebob cute cute
oh this is cute i actually haven't
played on my ukulele in so long i
thought i would have forgotten all the
songs i'm not gonna lie
i guess i just played them for so long i
kind of remember them
[Music]
i might have forgotten this one they
will see
[Music]
why is exchange
recycle my skin so i
can't begin to love
the shape we're having
[Music]
oh god no i have got it
[Music]
oh god
[Music]
no oh god i can't remember the freaking
lyrics
sad times oh well i could just
keep it but whatever i'm gonna get my
guitar out
because i remember i remember those
because i play them like
a lot ah guitar
damn i really thought that this there
would be more time in the day
like we gotta play among us scene well
i guess if we finish him on this early i
can still play you a few more songs and
answer a few more questions
where's um
i'll just play with something like this
for now
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
doesn't sound right sorry guys i should
have done this all before but
that's a lot to do today i didn't
realize how long it would take me to do
everything
oh yeah i'm going to play i'm almost at
about quarter past
so how long is that 15 minutes yeah
about 15 minutes
and then depending on how long that goes
we'll see we'll see what happens
i wanted to like sit and chat with you
but we haven't really had the chance
maybe i'll have to do that another time
because there were some things i wanted
to address but it's more just me just
rambling from my head so maybe i'll just
leave that
i'll just leave you in a state of wonder
now what was she going to tell us
never know
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
should be fine
[Music]
it is all going today i really don't
know where the time went
[Music]
do
when he used to be a singer in a rock
and roll
then he would write the songs and i'd
tremble at his hands
he's a failure and he used to be
the life and soul of everyone around
you'd never catch him looking up and
never seen
[Music]
don't cry child
you've got so much more to live for
don't cry too
you got something i'd die for and if it
comes
to the rain just be glad you
smile again cause so many
don't and so many go
unnamed people push right past me
shouting their exclaims a preacher
pushes me aside and asked to wash my
sins i said no
[Music]
and he's a failure too
and i used to need a couple people keep
my head down
well now i need to hold them all to keep
me on the ground
[Music]
oh i care of something
[Music]
[Music]
don't cry
[Music]
and if it comes to the rain
just be glad you'll smile again
cause so many don't
so many goes
yeah right so i've been um
trying this uh your stream showed up as
a suggestion while listening to lag
wagon
well well well i don't know what who lag
wagon are but um thank you for coming
bollocks
comics warning would totally leave a
buck if i
wasn't this terrible don't worry just
coming over and viewing is
totally totally good enough thank you
thank you thank you so much
um yeah yeah yeah so
i started to mess around the other day
and what i'm trying to do
is play this tune because i really like
it as soon as i can start playing this
on a loop without my fingers hurting
because i have this stupid thing right
i had this really bad habit why i bite
my fingers
and it's led to me biting this is
probably quite gross you don't need to
hear this but
it's led to me biting the calluses so as
soon as i
start to build up my calluses i bite
them off it's
disgusting it's really bad habit but i
need to stop doing that because uh
it hurts but anyway
well though of course it's gonna hurt
but um
yeah there's this tune i quite like it
and i just i wanna like play it more
[Music]
wait this goes
[Music]
and then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
doesn't have some eyes i just need to
like
play it play it more
[Music]
i just read jamie was like do you just
randomly kiss people i'm like why did he
ask me that and i looked up and then i
saw someone was like if i could be there
i could have been there i would have
straight up kissed ya
by the evil orange so he's asking the
evil orange if he
randomly kisses people or she randomly
kisses people
did you write that i guess so yeah i
don't know i don't really write things i
just
you know i've told you jamie i just kind
of pop my fingers on here and just do
something and i'm like that sounds nice
and then you know
like you just know or jamie you'll know
this like you you play something like i
play this
like
[Music]
and then i know exactly when it when
it's sound next like in my head it
starts going
and then like i know like i want to go
so then i just look for the chord that
sounds like
what's in my head and then that's that's
how you go on but
it's a very low slow slow slow slow slow
way writing especially because i'm still
learning
come on
there it is i got it
no i don't this is not what i wanted
where is it
i got it this is what i wanted
[ __ ] sake idiot
um is it love in my face
it is i've been branded um i've been
scarred by love
you know physically mentally emotionally
no i'm joking no i'm fine
um what should i play for you
whoa yeah i'm gonna sing that one
probably the last song because i gotta
get ready for the the
game and then if there's any time after
the game i can play some more songs for
you
but i don't have noticed that you guys
seem to like my
singing stream so i think i need to do
them more often like maybe once a month
once i go the month something like that
[Music]
but that was another song wasn't
what did i play on instagram i can't
remember
i was playing like a
i think it was by like olly
and then yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes this one
it could have been one lonely
fine let's try that one i'm basically
just talking to myself i'm sorry one two
three
four five six i think i played it really
high like
seventh
just like the others
it could have been
[Music]
okay could have been
one lonely
night
i'm just like the
others
but
[Music]
this is
[Music]
endlessly at least until
the end
please never fall in love again
oh please never find
love again
i'm doing the strumming all wrong by the
way but whatever
[Music]
please just text
[Music]
and i
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
love again
[Music]
something like that anyway i was um
i put up a video on instagram
jagmax.music
my music instagram account um
because i was going to play that for you
today ah we have five minutes
do you think i could play another song
it's a quick one maybe i can
fleetwood max dreams i can i can have a
look at it
live gigs every month yes yeah it would
be nice to sing more songs with you
again jamie i want to like
actually sing songs in pubs and stuff i
don't know i miss that
i miss singing live i do miss that
not that i did very often but i still
miss it
don't forget we are uh now have a target
of 400 pounds
for um age uk the
link is uh in the description but i'll
also
put it here in the chat for you
thank you so much to everyone who's
already donated um
it's bloody crazy my initial goal was
200 and we
smashed that so uh yeah let's see if we
can get up to 400.
okay i'm just gonna sing one more song
and then we'll
we'll start playing games game time
right
got it whatever
oh wait this is way too high i'm never
going to be able to do that
[Music]
time
[Music]
no you can't combine and it touch you
wrong when you're ready to be strong
no you can't come by anytime
that you want when you're ready
to take me on
no i won't pray
[Music]
no
[Music]
forget the way that i can't ask forget
touching my hands
[Music]
[ __ ] your breath in your lips
just because you can't
no you can't come by any time
that you want when you're ready
to be a man
no you can't come by anytime what you
want i won't take you just because i
can't
[Music]
[Laughter]
when
[Music]
right arm of guys who'd wanna take me
on but there was something about you
it made me act like a fool and now
i want you gone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
okay there you go last song
my friends i'm ready to play now so i
need to i need to um get set up to play
with them
so thanks so much for listening
ah um game time it's game time
yes it is uh
right let me set everything up
thanks guys really enjoyable thanks
bollocks thanks jamie
thanks so much that's so nice cheers
bollocks cheers
thanks sidney there okay i'm gonna set
up
the house how's my um oh
we got some more just get finn oh yes
yes yes yes
here we go 305
we're so we're we're doing so good guys
oh yeah put in that five pound from
maria i spelt it wrong why did i say
marissa's pizza
i'm sorry maria i supposed to put marie
he's yet but you know what i mean so
maria
gave me five pounds like so i just put
the whole five pound in youtube takes a
cut
but whatever i will cover that cut so
five pound from maria and the
100 pound for miles jesus christ thank
you so much miles that's amazing thank
you thank you thank you
thank you that's so good thank you so
much
awesome awesome so we've got less than
100 pounds to go it's amazing
so good so good um
just so you can see it here you go see
here we got
miles and we got um money from
maria's pizza sorry i meant maria
anyway let's go back to here
okay i'll get i'll get the game up um
amongst yourselves have have a happy
time
lovely songs thanks thanks sam thanks
sam
great stream thanks oh thanks for coming
hey patch
thanks for the thumbs up air roar ever
i don't know if that's how you say say
it
thanks for coming nikki have a nice
first
stream have a nice rest of your day
um okay also i'm i'm just gonna say
i know like you're impressed that like i
had like an outfit change and stuff i
didn't i just had to jump around i took
it off
but still there was some thought behind
it
um okay let's get them all messed up
happy valentine's day peregrine
i got a list as long as
[Music]
ah i love her i don't know why she isn't
like bigger than what she is
she's so good honestly i've guys
is the game to gain too loud let me know
guys
[Music]
i just call myself a really stupid name
no one's gonna know it's me now
[Music]
um
okay
[Music]
shush
one imposter
okay
fyi said oh
i just say my my invite code out loud
no one knows
hopefully it won't take long for like
all my friends to come in because last
time we did this it took so long to come
in
i can't believe i just signed like to
say the code out loud it's
such an egg
there we go sweet
wait
that works i feel like such a nif
sorry i will be back with you in a sec
i'll have to
phone my friends as well so you can hear
the beautiful voices
i've said my pin number out loud while
paying for stuff oh no i hate that
that was totally something that i would
do as well
wait what
bye here we go
oh what the [ __ ] oh my god okay guys i
thought that i
kept making a public game because
freaking
brayden renamed his name to something
completely different
so i thought that there was a random
enjoy
and i've just quit and made two
different lobbies
because of him
oh it's infuriating that boy
password one two three
top hacking skills password one two
three
oh so i i had a lobby all like
done up and then bloody braden
confused me and then i
so i i quit out and i went to make
another one and the game just crashed
and i was like oh
why why are you doing it oh
dear right let's try again and let's
let's just
trust my own judgment okay okay
h g said said
oh god i sting again stop
jesus oh i stopped myself don't worry
i've told my friends that we can start
the call whenever
they are ready
so be ready for them to to show in the
scene
oh there you go it's joe joan britain
it's brayden
oh dear dear right here we go
yeah never tell me he has a secret she
has to type out well i already have to
type out a secret
but then you know you're all right well
i mean i wouldn't tell the falsely i
just started the
the first half and then leave it as a
cliffhanger
oh no now not everyone can join
darth
i don't know if everyone else has this
problem with among us but whenever we
play
it's like it takes there's usually one
or two people that just cannot join for
some silly reason
oh yeah how is the game audio impressed
is my audio i think it's okay right
yeah that's that's braden jo jo britain
oh i need to update my twitch so you
guys know what i'm doing
just like the others
[Music]
this is what it's like
to be
you and me will never be
lonely again
well i think they're ready to call so
get ready to hear them guys
new category among us yeah
hello
oh i can't hear anyone hello
uh
okay
i bit him off yeah that's gonna be a
thing
what's gonna be
the fact that we've got a few jagmans
do we have two jagmans yeah look at the
name
no we have three eggmans there's a baby
oh yeah baby yeah
okay so who can't get in there's two
people right
me like not
oh should we say hi um okay so i'll just
go
uh amy
jackson yeah
[Laughter]
nathan hello there
jordan how to do
i'm brayden all right
cool
oh i've already told everyone braden
that i got annoyed at you for
for putting the stupid name in i thought
it was quite clever myself
and then i left
and i left and then you were like why
did you leave and i was like oh because
i was getting so confused i thought it
was a public one
i'm gonna relock my game and see if it
works that way yeah
um what did we have to do last time amy
did you make sure it's that you use
servers well you're observer as well
yeah we just have to keep trying like
just it took forever is it just nathan
and jax that can't go
oh uh apparently i can get in on my
phone but i can't get in on my computer
so oh nathan's here i relaunched the
game and i immediately got it
okay nathan relaunched the game wait
epic
is that everyone that's everything
okay let's do it who's the real yag man
that is the question
well jagman obviously
[Music]
yeah which meaning i'm number one
meaning the actual one
no i'm zero like before can you tell by
my voice
i'm infinite things don't sing something
then i'll
know
you're not the real yak man
come on jordan i bet you can't even name
five of her songs oh that's so true yes
turn from the spot he's like oh [ __ ]
all right um obviously
there's she um did a tiny little robot
song
i think it's called tiny little robot
that might have been the working title
oh i don't know i'm so bad at these
things she also did a punk rock version
of sweater
that's true i did a fun crop version
that was fun which is
[ __ ] awesome i'd like that oh thank
you
i'm going to turn nathan up because
nathan's nathan's uh
quieter than everyone else wait i don't
know what i don't know what's happened
to my discipline
uh it's completely killed itself on
everyone's anyone who i talked on
discord just said wow you've gotten
really quiet like i've done
nothing do you have multiple microphones
with like a webcam mic oh okay i've just
got my headset
to be fair discord does sometimes change
your settings out of nowhere
it does it's a pain well i've turned you
up so hopefully
should be easier to hear now i think
everyone else's levels are good
well done i mean
what the hell was that noise
i think jordan's sword is like
oh oh you're happy fans want to say guys
ah yes thanks happy valentine's day to
you too love you
shut up i have a message here from amy
saying i love you happy valentine's day
so
you can't what it's secret what is the
meaning of this
i got a valentine's day message from my
gay best friend oh
that's cute yeah see
i've known him for like 15 years i
[ __ ] hate valentine's day
but i like i like that so i got bitten
by my cat
is that love bite oh god
i don't want to bring the level of human
doubt quite so far
so many people have clothes on well i
say so many people half the people have
clothes on
oh yeah we feel nude we can do things
how do we do that no clothes
i can't believe i finally got on the
[ __ ] pc and it wouldn't connect my
phone just like smashes me in
i'll see you on your phone again but i
have a copy because game pass does it
but
uh it just didn't want to go on my
computer for some reason
i don't know if it's a firewall issue
maybe i don't care it's my phone i'll do
beautiful oh my god
right i chuck one of my children out the
airlock because
um do you want to change like discussion
time maybe or something
i don't know is that enough time
oh say never mind that's like yeah
no no discussion time is like beforehand
voting time is
yeah two minutes is plenty
what's the uh kill cool down on
15 seconds with six people that might be
quite quick although there's not many
tasks
how do i change it
go to the laptop there should be a thing
that's like settings
settings on the laptop yeah
oh my god oh my god
sarah closed youtube oh because we
inactivity
foxy i didn't know that was gonna happen
okay right next time i'm gonna make one
now and then we just
we just do we just do
we do do yeah you can adjust the
settings really quickly
i didn't see how to do it i've never
like done this before
it's if you go on to it there should be
a very right tab for you that says like
settings in there
and then you can adjust them or you can
do i don't know if you can do them
[Music]
there we go in straight away well do you
do you actually need me to
change oh here we go on the game right
yeah um what do you mean i might
recommend
uh turn visual tasks off because then
it's easier to be the imposter because
then you can like you know
because as people can see that you're
not doing one of like the visual ones
okay fair fam yeah and with only one
imposter they kind of need the help they
can get
yeah uh 30 seconds kill distance normal
it's fine
um and then it's up to you really from
there i normally have player speed on
1.5 but
if that's yes i'm on pc
yeah you called jackson
i have i have clothes now i'm a narc
disgusting uniform or is that a
policeman
that should be fine i think it's a
policeman i'm gonna be an ark
where are we oh you're there i'm yellow
i'm the minion
oh minion
look amy i've got leave for your apple
[Laughter]
green i would die if i was green i would
die
is there a sprint but no there isn't
america no no that's
the speed you go at let's make a macro
flick
bye sam jones thanks for joining oh
valentine's pizza hell yeah
enjoy that pizza okay let's actually
you're under arrest
there was one imposter oh yeah i forgot
about this
i have to do this there we go right
i forgot i had to meet myself okay am i
the imposter guys no i'm not thank god
okay um blue if i was green i would die
if i was green i would die oh here we go
right
what are my tasks fix the lights fix the
lights
oh no that's unfair yes smells who
changed their name
who was that that was jordan
look at him
guys i die straight away that's not fair
that's just me
why has he just did that i think he's
pretending to do a task
oh can i do things when i'm ghosty
so i'm still very newbie here to this
game
nice well at least i can do things what
am i supposed to do here
finally oh my god two of two
i see men dead but
i didn't rayden's also dead how did you
kill two people
because he's our new ninja because he's
yeah it was
outside the plant room is it called is
it the plant
like where the
the one next to navigation oh um
yeah that one it's been a while since i
played this yeah same i i ran a whole
lap around the thing thinking
thinking that i was on one side and then
i was supposed to be on the other
um because i have no idea what
happened yeah i'm like that
so she was just in the corridor uh i
came down from the
shooty bit uh the the cannons and uh
came down and she was just in the
hallway outside o2
i saw
who fixed the lights
is that well the
yeah so he was i was like doing a task
and then he appeared it must be jordan
then
yeah all the way down there guys
if you want to talk about anything
jordan you want to defend yourself
he's muted okay we boom then
oh yeah okay
he didn't stick up for himself he's gone
oh wait who did the guy
good because it was him good rfp
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
i honestly couldn't think of anything to
defend myself with not gonna lie
yeah i mean if you're on the complete
like i didn't see you at all
and then i'd only seen amy and nathan so
that's the only one left i saw was when
i got to
find amy yeah yeah i got to electrical i
saw you guys that was there
because i expected someone to be in
there dead so i was like ready to press
the report button but no one was
sorry um i was expecting
jordan to just flip it back on me like
oh you you were really
like sure about that her punk and then i
would get kicked out
but it was fine instead he was real bad
quiet
yeah i honestly didn't know what to say
to him
been a while i'm not used to lying maybe
we're all really bad at this game
because we're just
not like inherent i don't know lies
we're not good at fibbing
i must not tell lies one must not tell
you guys
do not want this bandana right there we
go
ninja that was done
it didn't seem like there were many
tasks but is that just because there's
not that many of us
uh there isn't that many tasks to be
fair
but i i mean i did spend my entire round
running
the wrong way
okay so maybe if we start smashing the
tasks that we should
increase them
let's go again
i just totally started the game without
well jackson was talking i feel bad now
sorry jackson
janks man jax man x for [ __ ] sake
wait what's my storage fix for wiring
communications upper engine
fixed wiring what's this
reactor meltdown
jesus it feels so big
what's this
is there anything up here because i got
a fixed wiring so
here we go
what is this
hello what was that
he died
from jackson um it was at the bottom
um just like sort of to the
left of the electrical corridor like
that really i was just running past that
and i didn't see anything
oh really oh yeah yes
no i literally was why would i say that
where was it because i was trying to
figure it out i was just
in there even though you're playing dumb
so you can pretend did you see anyone
else because i came
down like um braden was following me and
i was like my god i'm gonna die
i was like i was actually with i was
with braden
and uh i'm pretty sure it was jackson uh
because we had to do the
the other thing on the left i don't know
the hand thing the hand thing we had to
do the hand thing oh the reactor yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah that's the only person
oh maybe it was you and braden then it
was you and braden then maybe it wasn't
jack
yeah i knew it was blue yeah i went in
there and watched people but
yeah i watched because i was like oh
right there i don't know who the hell
it was that's all i saw i was waiting to
see if someone was pretending to do it
because sometimes people do that
that's so the only people did you see
anyone near it amy
i mean after the reactor i just went up
into medical and did that one
tasks there's like not a lot
nathan uh yeah i was in navigation on
the other side of the ship and i've seen
no one oh again and nobody saw you
yeah because i haven't seen anyone oh
well we got 30 seconds what are we going
to do guys
i think we just pass yeah i think we
passed it i don't know
okay
[Music]
right so i've got a i've still got to
fix the wiring
i've really got to learn where bloody
everything is i'm gonna
really get my eye on the ball so i know
what i'm doing
there we go
fix the lights
see jack seems like it it doesn't take
very long to do your tasks
maybe i'm just i just get lost so easily
i
don't do my tasks for ages
i want to do it i want to do that i want
to do it i want to do it i want to do it
i want it i want to do it
me and amy did it together that's so
cute
why is the bloody thing pointing me
there i can't do anything
uh
oh what's this
how do i know
one two one two six
one two oh maybe it's just one two
three oh god
who was that any mean right so it's
definitely not amy
stay away from me
i can't fix wiring oh the door shut
i'm locked oh my god what the [ __ ] just
happened
who was that someone just locked the
doors on me
i was just behind yasmin before you shut
the doors on me
yeah i know i know it says shirt as well
and i literally he just locked himself
in there with me and i was like
[Laughter]
i didn't know if anyone saw me in there
with you and i was like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah no i think you're just too far
behind amy you walked past
my body
[Laughter]
wait where i was on the i was on the
stand in the med bay
see me i jumped out of the vent and i
was like [ __ ] he's there and my kills
was on cooldown i was like stood there
waiting i was like
it ticked down it came off cooldown i
was like screw it
killed you and then jumped back in the
vent again yeah
i was in the animation i couldn't do
anything
[Music]
oh thank god for that
wait i just need to have a look i think
we've reached our just giving goal so i
don't know if you guys know but we
are raising charity for wasting charity
raising money for
um age uk and
the um the goal was well it was 200
pounds this morning
and i had to up it because we reached
that goal so
400 pounds and we've just reached 400
pounds guys
oh wow let's have a look i just want to
see who
oh my god miles miles bloody hell
miles he gave 100 pounds
and then afterwards just decided to just
randomly give another 95 pounds
thank you much yeah
absolutely crazy uh the chat are asking
whether we want to
up the just giving page do you think i
should
if you've reached it already why not
yeah for streaming
all right i'm gonna up it to 500 why not
let's see if we can just have
100 more pounds in an hour thank you so
much guys oh god i can't believe it i
literally
ah i was trying to do something i was um
so i think all you guys know that my
mum's like a carer right
yeah yeah yeah so i text my mum this
morning
and i was like oh mum is that is there
any way that i can like give
to uh the like carer place that you work
for directly
through like just giving or something
she's like what do you mean i was like i
want to like donate or set up a donation
today
and then she was like oh um i don't
understand what are you going to donate
exactly do you want me to phone later we
can see what kind of things you can
donate and i was like
money mom like chairs
so do a little song yeah yeah
so nate my music microwave would you
like that
yeah exactly like what she think of
money my money
but no they weren't on just giving so i
thought oh age uk
because i think it was sam jones one of
my subscribers said it and i think it's
a nice idea on valentine's day to give
to like
you know the old young people yeah might
be a bit lonely today
yeah it's awesome all right i'll just
quickly
edit it and then uh we can play another
one did you
oh what yeah because
it didn't continue oh my god so annoying
[Music]
yes man
i can't believe my subscribers are so
nice
and they like distract me by giving me
me money on the just giving page
day
good one
i keep doing that i keep going to read
out the code
the among us code i'm just like oh
and then i stop on like the last two
letters
hopefully you can all get in here oh
wait
it's just like every time oh it's jake
you
[ __ ] no can't say that yeah yeah and
someone in the chat said that they've
done that before their pin code
when being like taking out money i was
just like oh no
i don't want to do that no no no no but
that's totally something i can see
myself doing so
it's easily done to be fair that's
something i can see you doing
as well yeah just need to stop talking
so much just shut up
[Music]
okay 500 pounds upping the target
crazy yeah
joe bart bryden i'm arresting you
on suspicion of interfering with the u.s
election
that's a negative back
i've been authorized by the f would be
i
thanks for following pashmina and also
diarrhea asmr
now that's samia's more i would listen
to it
is it diarrhea or is it dire here
i don't know i'm sorry if it's not
actually diarrhea
oh no
sorry but anyway
let's play before we get kicked out
again
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
guys it's my time it's my time
i've got a [ __ ] kill yeah
yeah [ __ ] yes screw you braiden
there was a body wow that was fast
if it was fast we know he's fast
what jordan you just told me i walked
like up the corridor and he was there
yeah where was he
wait where was the body then what side
were you on
uh we were on the right side
you go up a little bit in which yeah
can you tell everyone else i can't hear
you
yeah you kind of crack crackly a bit amy
is this better yeah oh yeah yeah yes
so where was the body anyway who found
it amy so it was me
i just saw you jordan and i walked up
that corridor and there's a vent on the
corner
that's where he was like by that then
right okay
why navigation if he was by the vent
i was on the cannons and jazz
came up from the area of the vent in
cafeteria ran up towards the entrance of
the room and then ran back
yeah right there because i run past her
and
uh brayden to go down no i was that i
was with um
amy and braden but then i turned around
because my task was in the center of the
room so i decided to just go
back through the cafeteria again
convenient
yeah i went down uh to electrical
uh uh i went down with poops where's the
electric
electricals down bottom left bottom left
yeah i went down into storage and he
went down past me because i had my wires
in there and then i went and did my
download
in communications and that's where i
thought amy was kind of stood outside
of comms
yeah i just figured out how to get my
map up
because i'm a noob yeah no same i don't
know any of the
places yet are we doing we skipping or
i guess so we haven't had much jackson
sounds like he's smiling
does he have like a smiley face
you never smile it's like a [ __ ] old
door
oh voting's ending what we can do oh
fine skip it
wrecked some aggressive there's some
aggressive
day but okay
jamie are you not a mod on twitch sorry
i thought you were mods
um i'll see what i can do
right okay i think i shouldn't do it too
quickly this time guys
but that one wasn't too bad this lying
like
makes me anxious
we gotta find more people
what i've got to wait 20 seconds so i
can kill again no this isn't fair what
are my fake tasks how do i do them
okay
where was the body lights
the only two i didn't see then no only
one i didn't see that was jazz
okay convenient because i was doing i
yes
because i did wires over in um
navigation i ran down to finish my comms
because
the body got called last time before i
finished uploading then i went to
admin where i saw jackson and amy
we crossed over twice because i crossed
past you to go into navigation and then
i crossed you and comms to go into admin
so
yeah i'm getting for voting yes wait why
wow you changed your tune quick amy huh
well you i was doing
um doubt no upload and you stood there
for a while and you didn't care about
that
yeah yeah because i'm still not too sure
what i have to do now i went to the you
know the one on the left where you like
make the ship line go in line with the
ship line with the line
yes the exact thing yes exactly what's
it called
on the vehicle between the right right
no on the left wait on the left with the
ship you have
your thruster realignment yes the
rosters
oh well it is valentine's day after all
well that was what i was doing
well if it's on the left and it was at
lights and
who's your vote
is it did we have to just throw up i
mean to be honest the only person i
didn't see was yes
it does also doesn't mean it was an aim
because amy was quite quite aggressive
yes i mean if if if it's not just me i'm
just
what i feel like jackson could have
killed you i feel like it's either
jazz or amy yeah we chilling we pros
oh oh i see if we've got this is
awful because it's like a timer until
somebody can
kill
no
[Applause]
did you pop out of the vent then in
cafeteria
or did you just come from that area and
i thought that you were in the vent
wait when for the first kill uh
did you kill someone on the vent and
then and then pop out into the cafeteria
yeah yeah
okay all right yeah that's what i did i
didn't press i didn't press i saw braden
and i was like i have to kill him first
braden you're muted oh sorry my bad
i'm just so used to being dead now i do
that far too often
all three of my tasks started electrical
oh man straight back down there
straight murder either like
well [ __ ] not gonna i thought i was
gonna get voted out purely because the
last
two before that i was impostor and i was
like no
i think that actually that's in your
favor i think
because yeah i mean the chance of me
being the imposter again are pretty
are supposed to be pretty slim but
sometimes you either get it constantly
or just never yeah i would be the latter
oh thanks undress but sorry this is just
like we're just playing with friends
today
but thanks though so yeah we don't want
it i feel like
when i say yeah it's just a valentine's
day princeton
no stranger things look like i'm tea
bagging amy come back
no and um pashmina i would just
for advice for a mod um just
if you have 5k on twitch that's great
just ask like your community like anyone
who watches you
on the regular ask them if they want to
be a mod all your friends
um anyone like that uh yeah
but i don't think it's a good idea to
like ask
random people because you need to trust
them first um
so yeah that's my advice
right uh should we play again
yeah i want to go killing people
oh i think i think once i once i get to
know this game more like as in all the
tasks and where everything is then i'll
actually be a better imposter you know
what i mean because most of the time i'm
just like
i don't know how to uh justify where i
was or what i was doing because i hardly
even know most of the tasks
so i'm just like i'm struggling to
remember where where the tasks were
yeah yeah
okay i'm a dumb scientist
we all are done right
okay it's not me this time thank god
right let's see if we can actually do
all of our tasks that is
um that's what i want to do admin card
vitamin electrical
gotta do this for some reason
except diverted power electrical and
i've got to go to the right oh god amy
is scary i don't want to be
hello hello nathan
marty was in uh the far right navigation
i think
oh again far right navigation all right
the room on the far right
yeah yeah that'll be navigation and then
uh someone vented
there oh you saw them i just saw the
vent bike flip open or
close oh did you see anything in storage
um did anyone see them
because who was in o2 with me that was
me
oh that was you okay did you
run down to shields but the only other
person i saw
i think it was jackson but he ran
straight down past or two but i just i
don't know where he went
i went straight to shields i was with
amy um we were in electrical
never in storage oh i wasn't electrical
i did see i was like doing a task in
storage just like came down past me
yeah so it's got to be jordan
or jackson well it's not me
okay cool saw you
we vote out um jackson now
if that's not it next round without uh
jordan how's that
okay fine
braden the leader we'll follow you joe
wherever you go
[Music]
oh that was fast yeah literally said i
wanted to kill people and only got to
kill one
[Music]
would be like more easier to misdirect
but uh oh funny
there's just before christ yeah we're on
the opposite side of the map
weird thing is you have to try and be
seen by everyone
but seen in like away from where the
bodies are going to be found
i guess which gets increasingly the best
thing for doing now
yeah i should have been thinking more
about where everyone was because i
should have expected brain to walk
straight
i mean you could have gone straight down
and not even got anywhere near a
navigation but
did you have a tablet yeah what did you
just post i went straight down to bloody
shields myself that's why i was a bit
like
no i was just looking because that's
what i do i'd check out people
yeah yeah make sure there's no [ __ ]
bodies hiding in corners you can't
otherwise you've run past the same room
15 times you don't realize there's
someone in there so they're dead
yeah that's good job i did oh yeah well
not for me
not enough for you but you're gonna
exactly
thanks for following sees left twenty
oh my god you've
we're going to go left this time let's
do this where's the admin card
oh no i feel like i'm very alone uh here
which probably isn't a good thing
can i do anything here now
engine right let's do here i'm sure
there's something to do here oh here we
go fix the lights
there we go
can i swear oh
right it's i it's gotta be braden i
don't know
i was just doing the card thing i looked
back off amy was dead
because i literally ran out of there i
saw you running in i went down to
thinking i thought
i'll go up and see what's going on have
a look and then i saw a body there and
then but then again
i don't know why you'd hang around if
there was a body if you actually killed
that don't
argue his case for him i want to be back
he wasn't stood over it
but i'd maybe you can move
yeah but he if anything he would have
like vented
and he was stood doing the cut by the
card thing so i'm not sure
i went in she was on the little thing
you know pulling levers whatever went to
the car thing when i finished it
she was dead sir
i'm an idiot uh where is this thing
sorry yeah oh
it's in it's in the entrance to admin
where's that sorry it's uh
straight down from cafeteria first
um right as you've run down oh okay or
any of you in
oh yeah between there and storage were
any of you in storage
i was in storage and then i ran back up
to did you see yasmine run past you
no i didn't okay no i went to electrical
and then went back out and then i was
like
i don't know what i'm supposed to do i
looked at my mouth and realized i had
two more things to do in electrical so
then i
ran back that's why that's funny
uh i don't know because i didn't see
anyone apart from drugs i was in lights
the whole time so
i think it's nathan because he was
acting he's very suspicious and i was
watching amy
about both them in in the weapon toy
room
and nathan just sort of nathan where
were you because you didn't actually see
where you were yeah
that's where it was on the right hand
side with the um
it was a top right hand room and then i
ran
yeah then i went down uh down the right
hand side
i don't know what the room was i say
braden because he got me last time and
i'm sorry
i don't know what are we doing it's
jordan i'm gonna say it's not me jordan
uh i honestly i don't know because
obviously braden was in the room
but i don't see why you'd stay in the
room and not vent out if you killed
someone
or run out the other way so i'm skipping
i don't
[Laughter]
right if i die now it's braided
okay i've got a big arrow pointing this
way so i'm ready this way
so we think it might be braden or
possibly
nathan so
jackson's good we can we can trust
jackson this time
oh why is it so dark in here
uh where am i going okay i gotta go back
to electrical
scared
no no i don't i don't trust stop
stop ah i don't like it they're both in
here
hmm they're both just walking around
together
this is terrifying i thought i would go
back to find one dead and then i'd know
which one
okay so nathan was stood in the corner
of storage
and then i looped around because i was
frightened he was gonna hurt me
and then the body of amy was sat on the
floor
as if he was covering over it so he's
basically on top of it not pressing the
button
see that this was really weird because i
bumped into braden an electrical and he
was stood there
staring at me which i was very scared
about and then nathan
came in and i was like oh my god they're
both here so i ran out wait
was brade i'm wait so who was dead on
the floor i thought he was terrible but
it might have been pink
oh my god it's nathan it's totally
nathan then because he was he was with
he was with braden
okay
you can uh you can say something now
give you the floor
nathan yeah
i uh no i reported him because i found
him and i've been trying to say i just
found saw jackson running away and then
oh you clicked the button
[ __ ] i thought i'd press the button no i
reported
oh that's what i've been saying i mean i
tried to report it
i mean my argument still stands i
pressed the report button but he was
stood on top of the body
so now i think it's jackson but
you've done it right it's fine it's only
if if
if jasmine and nathan vote for the same
person then
it's a time but if they don't then
nathan gets booted out and we win
except i found the body and reported it
and found you
yeah but i've already got the upper hand
here and
how do you have the other hand because i
i think it's jackson
no i didn't report everything
it was us because you both were together
oh
i just got a notification of someone
else giving money to the just giving
page exciting
what are we on now the big moneys
big monas i can't believe we didn't like
thank you sit away johnny
feels bad man for your 20 pounds we are
now at 420 pounds
for 20. oh yeah
oh yeah
okay nathan i'm still mad you killed me
first
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh boy here i go killing again
wait is it me oh my god it's not wait
i'm gonna all right here we go
i want to go with everyone why is
jackson just staying put
it's really creepy i was my tasks
admin shields oh shields
oh hello oh it's the worldwide's okay
it's okay
i'm so confused
okay it's not jordan hello hello
hello jackson mike is like fuzzy
i've clicked my mute switch but i'll try
again yeah it wasn't weird um okay so
what happened
who found that uh nathan jack yeah jax
was just
in the middle of cafeteria just dead oh
that's oh i don't think jackson moved at
all then because he wasn't moving for
ages and i thought it was really suspect
well wait it might be a self-report
because i went to do my download and
then went back into the middle room and
nathan was just stood there
just like chilling just not moving and i
walked past him to do my upload
it could be another self reporter and
jazz was watching me for ages i know
no i was i was because i was looking at
your cute little robot
i was like why is she watching me this
is really cool i knew you'd get freaked
out by it i was just circling you
so i just ran down and i was like okay
she's left
and then i ran down through um
into storage and then up into admin and
then run
was going across to electrical when i
saw that well when the body got called
yeah i saw i saw jordan going to
electrical because i was just coming out
of it
i think nathan's hella sauce because he
was just stood there for ages
i went from uh what was it the med bay
scanner down to the lights we all
appeared at the lights when
everything turned off and then turned
back on again and then i went up back to
the main room and that's when i found it
oh you just did that not moving when i
went to do my upload
and i might upload the whole time so you
what were you doing
was jackson not there then it was just
nathan no i was coming from
is it weapons at the top where you do
the download and then you walk
like down into the main room but i
didn't go fully into it i just went like
around the side to go down and do my
upload i didn't go like
into it where the table was i don't know
i think it's
really nathan wasn't electrical but he
was in that main room i don't know it
just released us
yeah i was in electrical with all of you
yeah i saw
that i went up to the main room and
that's when i found just stood there
you just stood there thought
maybe it was braden guys do you think it
was braden
do you think it's brayden i think it
might be brayden i need to go to admin
i mean i still think it's sprayed in but
maybe a celebration they would have
killed me surely
there's so much [ __ ] happening
oh my god okay i just saw
um at the bottom of electrical like just
out of the doorway
nathan running past a dead body
he didn't report it they then
just known you literally were running
past the dead body
i honestly didn't see it
eva yaz is playing hardcore smart this
game or it's nathan
i seriously have i 100 did not see it
because i'm doing my last task and then
reactor went off
although honestly because last time yaz
did it she didn't do any um sabotaging
and i'm not convinced she knows how to
do it properly
yeah you're probably right no you are
right
can you defend yourself nathan not
really
that's like [ __ ] right if it's jazz
then well [ __ ]
i just jumped immediately on it
well i'm dead bye
oh come on come on
yes okay here we go
i love that can you say anything well
not really because i am the imposter
literally i thought you'd seen me do it
no no
you you were just walking out of the
corridor and like the dead body was just
there i was like come on this is
yeah he was falling over on my screen
oh no he was already falling over on
mine so
but i was right i was like okay the
whole environment
okay i mean yes you were right i didn't
realize i tapped
my apologies i'm sorry i'm sorry tabbed
out
yeah because i was waiting for us to
start again but i didn't hear anyone say
we're starting again and my game sound
was off for some reason oh so
i literally was just there and so i i
went back into the game
as the animation of dying was on my
screen and i was like
oh [ __ ] i should have just
not yeah it stood there you were afk i
left you afk because i thought it would
be too
uh and then i came back again like a
minute later
and you were still there oh my god i was
like everyone's awful quiet and i looked
over there
and i was like oh no because i
i was saying to like my chat as well i
was like jackson's not moving that's
really suspicious like what the [ __ ] you
just went there i don't know yeah i was
just
uh should we call this maybe the last
game because i know
i know jordan's gonna go and have some
roast i probably need to make dinner
that's fine okay yeah at some point as
well
yeah yeah i should probably eat and
waste it away
waste it away
okay last game let's do this
who hasn't been the apostle yeah we've
all been imposter
amy i'm an angry next time
all right that's it all right
oh oh for [ __ ] sake
how do i sabotage things like what is
this
i don't know what i'm doing till i do it
i hate being this i'm not gonna last
very long why am i in the vent
all right now i need to be bi people
hello where is that where was the body
uh it was in the uh navigation one
right on the far right side right so
conveniently where you both ran off
after we were locked in the cafeteria
but poops um you ran
yeah i went down i went to the bottom
yeah i went down to admin because
i had two tasks in there i went to 02
and jackson peeled off to the navigation
do you think i'd self-report for a third
[ __ ] time in a run
maybe i mean it'd be pretty damn
daunting [ __ ] good at this cave
christ so i can vouch for amy i think
because we're supposed electrical
yeah i saw braden in admin
yeah i saw i saw jordan in admin as well
oh isn't she yeah i came straight down
from when it was thought you're in
shields that's awfully close to where
the body was found
where was it fired it's down like down
in the capital
thing so because we were locked out of
uh we are locked in the cafeteria me
nathan and jackson
and i was like oh wait it's fine there's
three of us in here they're not gonna
kill someone whilst there's three of us
yeah but then those two ran off i ran
down saw
braden in
admin straight away and he ran down
so i don't think it's braden um i didn't
see amy or jazz so
i was locked in storage like by myself i
was freaking out
but then i realized that no one else was
in there
i do that every time the door's locked
i'm like is it for me is it for me now
that's something for jackson so you guys
were locked in the
cafeteria when i was on the story yeah
right in the cafeteria
typically the only person for me who's
us really slashed would be nathan but
once again i don't know if he would
self-report twice about this
about it three times in a row man i mean
it didn't work the first few times
unless he did it because he knew it was
yeah i'm scared to say anything because
last time i was like it's neat then
everyone voted me off yeah so
true oh [ __ ] we've got nine sec eight
seconds what are we gonna do
i'm skipping
i need to make sure people see me
because that's where i always go around
i
hide from everyone so
right let's go follow some people i
think i'm just like worried because
like everyone follows me to see like
what i'm doing
right if i get oh i can go and do
something in navigation
my fake task right
no don't kill him just go past
storage let's go down to electrical
whenever like the kill button comes up
i'm just like oh
i can kill right now but no just go past
and pretend to do your tasks
why where the [ __ ] is everyone
we get jordan out then um
that's good because then he won't
be able to oh [ __ ]
i've just saw jordan run away from my
body
who you running towards me and then i
ran away from you and then
we ran into a body no i was coming out
of electrical
and then i went the wrong way because i
was like where the [ __ ] am i going
who did you see where was the body but
you went the other way so it wasn't you
it was in storage it was next to is that
next to electrical
yeah it's the room next to electrical i
was running so i was trying to do that
simon says thing and i kept failing it
so i was like [ __ ] this so i ran down
and then yes was running the opposite
way but then she saw me and then ran
started following me
and then i ran into the body in storage
yeah
so well me and nathan got locked in one
of the top rooms so if you wanted to
kill me
he could have killed me there oh yeah i
saw nathan a couple times when i was
doing
some thing and he didn't kill me either
yes he did a great job
okay yeah i had the thrusters thing
so i was bottom left then top left then
i got stuck in a room with mr joe brydon
yeah did you guys have fun absolutely i
think it's he has
i think it's jazz as well yeah what why
bring it from the body and then you saw
me and started following me
to the body if it was me then why
brayden i could have killed you earlier
yes you could have but you didn't i
think i ran away a bit too quick
do you not think i'd take the
opportunity to kill you if i could
the only person i haven't seen is jazz
no i didn't see you
so i don't
because we were both locked in a room
yeah okay true so we get rid of the jazz
if yeah then wow thanks
ending the game by getting kicks out
love that
happy valentine's day
i thought you were the whole time
i learned how to sabotage guys
the first time i sabotaged i pressed all
of the buttons
because i wasn't sure what i was doing
so i was like
so i locked every door i think and
that's what everything that happens
without my consent i did not consent
being murdered
[Laughter]
and i got murdered and i wasn't
impressed i know
i stood there just watching at the
bottom of the corridor so i stood there
and looked there for a second
and then she ran off so i went to do my
uh last fuel started filling up
so i run in and i was like i think i'm
dead
and then she killed me i just thought if
i got rid of you i might have a better
chance because you know the game better
than anyone
so i was like i should have gone into it
because i did have a task in there but i
didn't want to stack up because
stacking up still fun and then yeah i
paid the price
yeah then i was going to kill braden and
i was like no i need to stop killing
people as soon as i see them
yeah you kind of have to it's all about
timing yeah
yeah definitely i just see the button
going it's like kill and i'm like yes
i'm like no no stop stop
i need something to stop
but now that was my i mean that was only
like five minute game we could play
another one
if you guys want to i'm just thinking
about like dinner time
i was super quick i don't think um
mine's gonna be somewhere around seven
closer to seven i wouldn't thought but
mine usually is
so i'm okay for another game yeah me too
sorry
maybe i won't die first this time
i swear to god if i get targeted i would
scream
but you won't be able to hear me with me
okay let's go seems like a girl just
saying whoever it is
it'll be mine maybe it's my turn
hopefully
oh please don't be the impossible again
i'm so bad at it okay thank god
what am i doing navigation
yes
so who did we just see we just saw
jordan i think there was someone else
there but i wasn't really looking
amy i'm with amy jackson
hello hello hello where was that
what was it at the the entrance to admin
uh sorry what part of the map is that uh
the middle
if you're going down from the store hmm
okay so i wasn't there um i ran past
nathan when nathan was in the cannon
room that went into o2
and then i've been there since the name
has just seen me come out and yeah
yeah i saw jackson and amy oh two's the
one to the the left of where you were
like just running past who was in
cafeteria with me
i was doing the data at the top yes
another day of the the
bin shoot yeah and
i was following nathan and that's when i
saw him report it so it's not south
report
nathan was doing the turrets for the
entire time
i think i only ever saw jordan run past
me that way so that's where he died
uh and i don't think it's jazz because
she was on the
farm no she was behind amy so she'd be
even further away than
amy was unless amy saw her run from
somewhere
so that leaves jackson oh i was in o2
no i saw jackson yeah
like i came out of there so i would have
had to run through
the cannons and then through
to o2 and then back out again which i
didn't do because i was in there doing
the task
so amy no because she was
running past with him with jazz so it's
not me yes amy so it's
you or uh nathan it's not nathan and
it's not me
because it's you then right i'm gonna
pull my vengeance card again because i
didn't get
him who jackson
braden because i i didn't actually get
the satisfaction of bidding off when
i wanted vengeance last time so i'm
taking it out now well it's either one
of those did we just vote
braided and then yeah then after that
yeah
what do you say i watch it's not i watch
nice and do the turrets in the top right
and then he walks
doing it but i've i watched him just do
something exactly
it's definitely not nathan if you're
voting me fine but it's not nature
because i watched the entire thing
i've already been so [ __ ] suss
already it can't be me again
every time you see that you're watching
me for [ __ ] sake
[ __ ] [ __ ] i did
yeah be
later oh no oh
okay maybe what do we think guys
i think actually it might be one of amy
or jackson and that what they have done
is they were using the events wait
nathan's not moving is he just looking
at us
oh god we might be dead soon if it is
nathan oh
okay he was standing looking at us for
ages
okay okay jackson seems all right
electrical
body and electrical
electrical electrical
i don't think it was jackson i think it
was you amy
i think it was amy i just i literally
just saw jackson and he was going the
opposite way
but he could have vented oh no yeah he
could have oh
what was that jax yeah but i didn't
okay like no because
she was doing the bit with nathan in the
admin room
and then i was doing the wires in
storage and she was doing it with me
and she could have killed me then unless
you know it's a lot of words
i'm sorry that's what you get from
sewing me
tell me i'm using a lot of words i'm
speaking it's what you do you use words
[Music]
you should have kept nathan alive you
literally killed the person yeah
we were going to vote off trying to kill
people okay
you're not killing me should have killed
jackson so
how did you get to the other side with
like jasmine thinking that you
was it like we're in front of her she
just ran oh
yeah she just instantly ran
in killed me and ran round and i saw her
and she was like
directly behind yes and i was like
that's like stop stop
stop stop stop survive jordan then
we have no chance yeah that's it that's
why i hunted you down
oh rip if i'm ever a crew mate
just take out you first yeah that's the
that's
the strategy it's a good strategy all
right yeah
next time i'm sticking with a group
hello i immediately
had everyone jump on me it's like it's
nathan it's like it's not i'm not that
smart
i vote fear i know you did thank you
and then you got voted feel the love
feel the love
i tried me alive and then i got killed
after you're sacrificed
and braden just sounds us like whenever
you say anything it just sounds
my brain vengeance has been satiated so
you'd have to worry about it again in
the future
i got what i wanted i didn't want to
kill nathan as vengeance so
yeah what because i killed you first
then another round
yes unacceptable behavior
so i'm an acceptable casualty am i
yeah wow
okay well i'm good to go now if you guys
are
okay yeah yeah sure if that's what you
want to do
i'm good for whatever all right well
thanks for playing
it was fun that's fun i enjoyed it
the valentine's day had spent on my
computer anyway yeah
i've totally given that up yeah
self-loathing
dinner with myself no can't just cancel
on that one well i mean
sam jones in the chat did have a
valentine's pizza coming just for him so
i think that's a pretty good valentine's
day
he knows how to treat himself
god i love pizza right now i've got
gablin cooking and i had pancakes and
bacon for breakfast oh
nice hell yeah pancake and pancakes
pancakes
well that was good fun thank you it was
good fun thanks guys
have a lovely day everybody later
[Music]
there we go they have gone
and it's just us
oh well
how was that not a bad valentine's day
if i do say so myself actually i need to
get to the toilet so
i will be right back sorry about this um
one second uh brb
and i'm back
ah i think we'll we'll just leave
um wait we'll spend the last like 15
20 minutes just having a little chat
before i
myself go and have dinner 4 20 donation
how are we doing on that donation we we
look like we're nearly there let's have
a look actually
let's have a little look
refresh the page so 420
that's so so good i i'm so happy thank
you guys
it initially was 200 then i went up to
400 and now it's
4 20. who knew
wow thanks to everyone who has been
donating i really appreciate it
age uk it's a good cause
help the elderly especially in these
times where
they must be feeling really lonely
i'll just put the link in the chat again
just in case anyone's missed it
[Music]
got my capstock on
oh my uncle's next door was a world war
ii veteran
and was all alone in life so we used to
invite him to
to dinners with us oh he's passed away a
couple of years ago bless him
that's so lovely though of like you guys
to make sure that he has
somewhat around to chat to and you know
should not feel so alone and that's what
age uk is all about
um it's weird to think i mean especially
when you're like
young and stuff you think i don't know
you just don't think you'll ever
well you do know you're going to be old
but you just don't think about it you
know
and it would just be horrible to
to get to that place where you don't
really
have anyone or no it's just a horrible
thing to think about
i was actually a bit dark but i was
actually thinking about death yesterday
i was thinking about death you know how
it goes no i was watching um
i was watching the crown and i think
there was like someone died in the mount
mountbatten died um
and uh i was like thinking about it and
i was just like wow
it's like so even you actually think
about you're like well i'm gonna die one
day
like this is all i am you know what i
mean like
you it's so hard to process when you
actually start to
think about this is my life and this is
what it is and then like once it's gone
it's gone and
like this this is it and it's fleeting
it's so weird because you just think
it's like
this is everything but it's not you're
like a tiny part of
something so much bigger anyway and then
i was thinking about it and i was like
well
you know i'm doing quite well i've got
great friends like you just saw
um i'm in the career that i've been
striving for for years
uh like you know i love my family
um like things aren't perfect but
ultimately i'm having
a pretty good run i think and i was like
yeah you know what
i'm doing good well done well done me
and i think i think it's good to have
thoughts like that i know sometimes when
i say things like oh just remind
yourself that you're going to die one
day like it sounds pretty depressing but
at the same time i think it can be quite
enlightening
because you realize you're like oh all
those things that i care about and i
worry about
you know um the way people think of me
or the way i'm perceived or like how
much
money i earn and like how nice my car is
you know all these types of things
they really don't matter because you are
gonna just be gone one day and what
does matter is you know are you
investing in relationships that make you
feel happy
um have you found like a passion or a
talent to nurture within yourself
to give you a sense of accomplishment
are you proud of who you are you know
all those types of things
that's what matters so it's nice to
think and reflect on that exactly be
grateful for what you have
but also if you aren't happy with what
you have like ask yourself why
because honestly i i think it stems much
deeper than just
i want to have money or a nice car or a
nice house
it's like okay do you want a nice house
because you don't feel like you have
enough space
and is is there something you could do
with your own space now or maybe you
don't need a massive house maybe you
just need
a room like a separate room um
you know do you want a nice car because
you want people to think
better of you and if so you need to dig
in further and
ask yourself you know why do i want them
to feel better
about me is there something that i need
to change in myself is there something
that i need to accept in myself so i can
just be proud of myself without having
to have a nice car
and having had like people tell me how
nice a car i've got
do you know what i mean i don't know
it probably sounds like really cheesy
and cliche but
i think like everyone if if you ever go
through a little
quarter life crisis mid-life crisis
whatever if you're just feeling really
down
even just a few months of therapy is
really really good
really useful
spending money on things you can't
afford to impress people you don't know
very very true yeah
yeah i agree sydney i do think that
lockdown has given people the
opportunity to reflect on that
sort of stuff definitely now that we're
not going outside as much
not going to social events as much not
traveling as much
and we're being forced to spend more
time alone
that's the main thing forced to spend
more time alone and that makes us
reflect on like what do you actually
miss
what were you doing because you thought
you had to do it um
who do you actually miss
and all that kind of stuff and yeah i'm
just i'm lucky i've got friends like
like the ones you just listen to i
haven't seen amy
in like so long it's
mmm it sucks but you know we're
facetiming and i sent her a christmas
present
and it's gonna be her birthday soon it's
gonna be her birthday in
april um it sucks nice to see your
friends for so long but
it is apparently we got another donation
so i'm gonna stop
being being um emotional
and have a look at the donation page
again
we got up to 4 30.
who's this thank you ryan
thank you thank you thank you so much
430 pounds look at us
go yes
we're all so generous
oh that's cute you're welcome sydney
yeah thank you for um
being with me on valentine's day i mean
420 plus 10
fear no evil ah
email yes email yes i'd probably message
my mom back because she did try and film
me earlier but i was streaming so
i should i should already message her
back i'll finish the stream
and then oh maybe i'll give her a phone
call later
guys i finished the witcher 3 again
second time i got the ending that i
wanted
happy days so i can actually start
playing the dlc now
it's funny because i get loads of
comments telling me i need to play these
games like
last of us 2 and witcher 3 and stuff and
i'm like i have played them
i just don't play a lot of games
like that at least um
on like live stream i feel like there's
games that are good
to stream and games that are not good to
stream
and games like the witcher 3 especially
is not good game to stream um
games like maybe the last of us could
have been a good game to stream but i
just really wanted to be immersed in
that so any game that i
really want to be immersed in and i just
want to spend a lot of time in the world
not good to stream unless i'm going to
become a witcher 3 streamer only
um but yeah but i i find that witcher 3
that was like it's my time you know what
i mean
it's my game for me and no one else i
love witcher 3.
like i do love it so that's why i had to
play it again to get the ending that i
wanted
because i wasn't happy with my first
ending and now i can play the dlcs
and i freaking i love the music as well
it's just such a good game
and it's actually quite a shame about
cyberpunk but i knew from the start i
wasn't
gonna really be into cyberpunk i didn't
think i didn't like it i just didn't
think it was really my thing
oh yeah said nathan i had the same issue
i played
so i played the witch 3 my first ever
time i was borrowing it from a friend
and i played it for about maybe three
four hours
and i went to work uh i didn't play it
for like maybe two or three weeks
and then i went to play it again and
especially the beginning of the game
there's quite a learning curve
um and i just couldn't i just couldn't
remember what i was doing where i was
going how to do things i was getting
very frustrated because it's also one of
those open world games where
you have higher level uh enemies just
kind of roaming
so if you just started and you you
decide you want to explore the open
world
it can be quite brutal um
so i i gave up and i didn't have the
patience for it so i understand sednator
but
if you allow yourself like a whole
evening or a day
just to really enjoy it and get into it
fingers crossed if you like me and you
love narrative and maybe you love
folklore and um you know anything like
that
you will get sucked into the world and
you won't want to leave
it's so good
yeah that's true and i don't know pain
which i just don't
so when i play games for you guys i like
i feel guilty if i play it on my own
because i want to make sure i'm live
streaming for you
but it's like so different when you play
a game online
versus when you play a game on your own
because i could just be
moaning in my pajamas not caring
you know or just like stuffing my face
with loads of snacks
and just like wronging yeah you know
what i mean just
and not having to like speak or say
anything
i just play the game whereas when i'm
live streaming
i mean i'd like to look at least
somewhat presentable
and i want to make sure you guys feel
included i want to talk to you about it
um it's just yeah for me
it wouldn't work with the witcher 3 um
but
that is why i stream horror games
because i think horror games are
perfect to stream because well hey i'm
too scared
to play them alone and b um
[Music]
well maybe that's it no b it's it's
always
i find horror games are usually very
linear because um
linear games it's easier to control
uh the atmosphere um the
yeah the way the player is feeling
uh the tension build up all these sorts
of things is so much easier to do in a
in a
linear game and those games are just
easier to
to stream anyway and the reactions i
mean you guys
love seeing people play horror games i
think it's the same thing right people
like to watch people play horror games
because they're too scared to play
themselves
totally makes sense and a lot of people
stream horror games because they're too
scared to play them alone so they get to
look at the chat whenever they feel
scared which is totally what i do
uh i think you're less scared playing
our stream with them are not really
there yeah no i definitely
am if i was playing a lot of the games
on my own i yeah
it would be terrifying but i like
playing with you guys
although i gotta say i don't i don't
think uh
like i did enjoy the medium but i don't
really think it was that scary there
were some moments where i was like
damn that's spooky like creepy but i
wasn't
terrified by it i can't wait for another
game where
i'm actually terrified by it i don't
think there's any coming in oh
woman took him out wasn't evil 8
village they'll be out in may
and we'll be playing that and that
should be very scary
because president evil 7 was great
very excited okay it is seven o'clock
so does anyone have any questions for me
before i leave
should i just play a song before i leave
oh hell yeah yeah a little nightmares so
i'm gonna be playing little nightmares
next week next thursday we'll start
playing little nightmares fun times
uh and just so you know i am i know i've
said this a bunch of times but i am
getting ready to
move house so soon things are gonna be
extremely erratic
uh i'm probably gonna be kind of
stressed out and
uh content might be slow
or just not there for a while i've been
feeling a little bit
um just not very creative
and i think it's because i'm just
thinking about house moving
uh and how long it's gonna be it's the
first time i'm moving house where i have
to like
buy almost furniture and stuff which is
cool because it'll feel like mine but
you know there's just a lot of stuff to
figure out first um
so yeah i just wanted you guys to know
that
there might not be youtube videos or
anything i'll probably still
be streaming but and also i don't i
don't know recently i've just been i've
been getting a lot of anxiety when i've
been thinking about making youtube
videos there's stuff i want to talk
about
that i'm very passionate about but as
soon as i go to
write a script i just start thinking
like i get imposter syndrome and i'm
just like i don't know if i want to talk
about this and
i don't know it's just it's causing me a
lot of stress and honestly i'd rather
not
so i just i don't know i was talking
about it with um
with braden actually and he was saying
you know what do you want to be known
for in the future and blah blah
obviously it's it's video games it's
video game development and
maybe it's about time that i just stop
making youtube videos and literally just
focus on
trying to make a game in my spare time
instead of trying to like put up a new
video every few weeks or whatever
so there's more like
thinking i have to do around it i know
it's going to be a lot easier once i get
this next place and i have a whole room
to be creative in hopefully my creative
juices will just flow and i'll be
excited and i'll be doing stuff
but right now i feel a little bit burnt
out with everything going on so i just
want to let you know that
oh thank you why you brought yourself
love hearts because
love left me scones um um
what's it there's no something like us
scorned lady and no i don't know
i thought there was a saying but there's
not i'm i'm
scorned i'm scorned by love
but that's very nice to hear thanks
hinata
i'm also i'm getting ready actually i'm
gonna give like a little lecture
to a school which will be cute and
that's in less than a month actually i
need to get my ass and gift that
is it yeah well maybe a month
i've got a little bit of time but yeah
cute
cute things coming i'm trying to give
back i want to give back to people so
instead of like
just making all this like silly cutesy
content i want to try and give
back to people especially after women
winning the like tech women award and
stuff i have been going to
catch ups and like networking events and
they're all so
they're so amazing and everything they
do is to try and like help other people
um you're like they're making an app to
help
kids in school like girls in school
um see that women are in technology and
i follow them and then there's
you know people making documentaries
about women in tech and like
these crazy 13 year olds that are
starting like code clubs
and i'm just like wow and then
they get to me and they're like what
what have you done recently i'm like
i made a cinematic for
a song that i vote uh
and i just don't feel like i'm giving
back so
yeah i don't know there's a lot of stuff
this was me eating away at me i just
don't know like
what like what is the purpose you know i
feel like i just don't really there's no
purpose to it i do things because i
enjoy it and that's that's true and
that's nice
but i don't know i just
it these all these women they
had a purpose to what they were doing
you know they knew
what they wanted to get out of what they
were doing and that's
i lack that heavily majorly
like that and it's a bit annoying
so i need to figure it out
i remember you did one a while ago dip
on what
my school's going to be working with
into games soon oh that's so cool today
yeah from from my experience they're
great so
that should be really fun i hope your
kids your kids
the yeah your students learn
uh learn a lot from that i'm sure they
will
those lectures yeah well it wasn't i
guess
yeah yeah yeah it's nice i've been doing
i've been doing a bit more i've been
trying to help a bit more
i've got actually like a bunch of like
emails and stuff i need to reply to
uh
it gets overwhelming i'm not gonna lie
ah i wanna do stuff that makes a
difference it's so irritating
hey oscar tc3207
thank you for following
but yeah that's where my head's been
anyway um let's
sing a song before we go
hmm what do i want to sing
hmm ukulele or
guitar ukulele or
guitar tainted
love or a guitar song
let's do something slow
[Music]
oh yeah i could do dessert more okay i
was going to do um
let's move down but we could do this one
i think this was the right
sing the barney love song
i love you you love me we were greatly
we were happy family with a great big
high gonna kiss me to you
won't you say you love me too so weird
well production in the making that it is
so true
yeah me and jamie have been working on
uh producing a new ep we've got
two songs that are basically done we
just need to properly record them into a
studio
into a studio in a studio uh in his
studio
when it comes back to that uh
[Music]
and then how many songs would it be that
would be
deserve more get out uh
robot um
oh oh oh oh oh scared to sleep
um
and possibly that that quarantine song
that i wrote as well
i think that'd be quite nice
everything you wanted
[Music]
does it match up to what you
saw everything you need
[Music]
everything you work so hard for
you might have your money but
go
[Music]
[Music]
you pushed away your
be yours
oh you deserve moms
[Music]
for decor i don't have much
money but i have
something worth so much more
a future to grasp
if your hand will unclass
[Music]
don't i deserve more
and everything we wanted
i know it has changed from
before in our minds you planted
a vision of a life we can't afford
we'll waste all our money on
what you have shown a wheel boarded
as our own oh fill us
with floors
tell us we deserve more
[Music]
that you see as every moment
was it your choice you
made to replace
those who care
judgment keeps us tame
[Music]
to a place our dreams we're
[Music]
day
[Music]
there you go that's bloody top
there you go little goodbye song
oh cute thanks jamie
ah thank you so much for spending the
day with me i really really appreciate
it it's been
a lot of fun it actually went a lot
quicker than not that i thought it was
gonna be boring go really slowly but
you know it went a lot quicker than i
thought i was gonna go absolutely just
massively quick thank you tlk
um yeah i know today
it's gonna be weird whether you are
single or in a relationship
today is not gonna be like any other
valentine's day
because a lot of people can't even see
their other half
so kind of sucks but i hope that you've
made some time for yourself today
uh whether that be with pizza like sam
whether that be playing games with your
friends like me or whether that be like
watching a streamer and um just doing
whatever you want to do for fun
and hopefully you've done that with me
uh yeah
i hope you have a wonderful day um
thank you so much to everyone as well
who did give to the just
um the just giving page
for age uk i really appreciate it i'll
put it
here again i'll link it in the chat um
i can't believe we've gotten to nearly
500 pounds that's absolutely crazy
and yeah you guys are just so generous
um always just really great
it's so crazy it's been a different
valentine's for sure yeah for sure for
sure
let's have a look so how how much we are
i think we're still on yeah
430 that is absolutely crazy
you can still donate after the stream is
done
so feel free to if you want to
uh but yeah other than that have a
lovely evening
make yourself some food chill out do
something you love
uh and yeah enjoy yourself because it's
monday tomorrow
have a lovely day or evening i will see
you
next week on thursday because i usually
stream on a thursday at 9 00 pm gmt
and we're going to be playing uh little
nightmares too which i'm really excited
to play
i i it's good because i didn't play
little nightmares that long ago
so uh yeah i'm excited to play the
second game
gonna say goodbye to who i can see in
the chat so goodbye
uh clay goodbye jamie goodbye ib196
goodbye sidinator uh goodbye colin
williams
and thank you again colin for your
wonderful generosity
um goodbye
jandio oh no you just got here i'm sorry
i'll keep this up but every thursday at
9pm gmt hopefully you can make it
another time
i'll be back next week uh goodbye
uh c's left and thank you again for
following goodbye
candle ja can daughter do i say it like
that
goodbye anyone else anyone else uh
oh goodbye nathan
i think that's everyone that i can see
goodbye fear no evil if you're still
around
and yeah goodbye to anyone who i might
and have forgotten or can't see in the
chat
or anyone who isn't uh writing in the
chat
but is watching i still really
appreciate you being here uh
so yeah have a lovely day